back to that story that we teased with
jennifer griffin national security
correspondent about the firing back and
forth
between the u.s and iranian-backed
militias
u.s air force f-15 and f-16 struck three
targets on the iraq syria border the
pentagon says
that's where iranian-backed militias
have been assembling drones that have
been attacking u.s personnel at military
bases in iraq
in response hours later pro-shia
militias fired multiple rockets at u.s
forces in syria
targeting a u.s coalition base at the
oil field in deir azor
a coalition spokesman said there were no
injuries
iran will never get a nuclear weapon on
my watch as they say
i directed last night's airstrikes
targeting
sites used by the iranian-backed militia
group responsible for recent attacks
on u.s personnel in iraq the white house
responded to criticism from the iraqi
prime minister
that one of the air strikes was inside
iraq and violated iraqi sovereignty
the prime minister is a partner he has a
tough job
his statement called for de-escalation
from all sides and we agree with that
but the attacks against our troops need
to stop u.s officials described the
airstrikes as
necessary appropriate and deliberate
designed to deter iran and its proxies
we have been very clear the president
has been very clear throughout
that we will act to protect u.s
personnel
and given these ongoing attacks that you
referred to by iran back groups
targeting our interests in iraq
five times since april iranian-backed
militias have sent
small explosive-laden drones to dive
bomb into iraqi bases
where cia and american special
operations personnel are based
the u.s airstrikes were carried out a
little more than a week after iran
elected a hardliner ibrahim raisi
as its next president that's on
definitely what the u.s is doing
is disrupting the security of the region
and one victim of this instability will
be the u.s
itself we've just learned the u.s
military responded with artillery fire
today
inside syria when faced with those
incoming rockets
this as the u.s tries to return to talks
with iran about the nuclear deal
and iran refuses to allow monitors in
adding
it won't hand over the security camera
video from the sites where u.n
inspectors have been monitoring until
now
brett jennifer griffin live at the
pentagon jennifer thank you we'll follow
that story
today hey sean hannity here hey click
here to subscribe to fox news youtube
page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else